let's hear from some people in the
audience at davidpakman.com
discord
and um you can uh discord is free i'm
not selling you anything other than a
good time and we will hear from some
people because if you weren't here it
would be really weird let's start with
ricky from charlotte ricky welcome to
the program what's on your mind today
hey david i wanted to ask you about two
potential future scenarios that
uh i think are somewhat plausible and
could give the left some hope if they do
happen i just want to see how likely you
thought they were okay um the first one
being around the supreme court i see
that it seems now the the court is
completely politicized like all the
retirements will be
um
super politicized by all the justices
going forward but i do wonder if we
could hope that
roberts is not
as crazy as like the republicans like
you know the way the republicans are now
and he's and and and it would be
conceivable that at some point he could
retire when there is a democrat in
office i don't see that happening with
like alito or thomas or any of the crazy
ones but roberts is someone that i'm
holding up on do you think that could
happen i mean
sure but he's only 67 so you know if
history is an indicator it's not
happening anytime soon it's not
happening soon enough that there's
really any reason to speculate now
because it could be decades away
um
yeah i mean
67 is
i mean you know maybe it could be like
10 years from now i mean you know if
he's been on the court for like uh 20
years at this point
i don't i think i saw like the average
justice serves like around 20 years or
something like that so okay
i mean listen there's nothing we can do
about it it can't be part of any kind of
strategy i guess is my point because we
don't know when it would happen anyway
yeah but
i i just don't see that it would happen
with anyone else uh and if it happened
with him i feel like that would you know
that could
um bode well for us but okay the second
one i just want to ask about really
quick um
if
the you know trump and desantis or other
republicans go ahead in the primary if
trump loses
i feel like he will do another it was
rigged against me and
um you know the establishment of
stealing from me is like stop the steel
bs and like cause the republican the rnc
like the same headaches that he's called
like the whole country and stuff um do
you see that happening do you think if
that did happen would he potentially run
as a third party no i think i mean maybe
but listen so here's the deal trump
would never win as a third party and of
course if trump fights for the
republican nomination and loses he will
say that it was rigged and stolen from
him by the rhinos but then that'll be it
you know he'll be like almost 80 and
he's not going to run at age 84 and that
that'll kind of it'll be it so yes it'll
be annoying and he'll do it but then
then we'll be rid of trump
do you think that would damage
the uh whoever the nominee is in that
point like the republicans the general
if he ran as a third party candidate no
no if if he lost and like attacked the
primary yeah exactly uh no probably not
oh dang
okay man i was hoping for i think what
would hurt republicans is just a really
long and
um
contentious primary i think that that
would be bad for republicans
yeah i because i remember last time
before the primary ted cruz actually
seemed like a politician that could win
an election and after trump humiliated
him i don't see him ever like winning
i mean never say never but he seems like
super weak now so yeah anyways thank you
david all right ricky from charlotte
thank you so much uh very very much
appreciate that one of our sponsors
today is bluechu a unique online service
delivering the same active ingredients
as viagra and cialis in a chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost and
they're giving my audience an entire
month supply for free so if you think
you could benefit from an extra boost of
confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping